[APPLAUSE]
SYDNEY FINKELSTEIN: Thank you.
Thanks, Heather.
Hi, everyone.
Thanks for having me here.
It's good to have
a chance to share
some ideas around superbosses.
And I'm really
interested in what
you have to say about that.
And I'm going to have some
questions for you as well.
A professor can't help
that type of stuff.
So let's start
with-- I'm a foodie.
I'm really into
great restaurants.
That's why I live in Hanover,
New Hampshire, for example.
And one of the things I noticed
in the early days of getting
interested a little
bit about talent
is I heard about this woman
that, after graduating
from college, she
went to France.
And she lived the Paris--
the Parisian lifestyle.
She went to the markets.
She always had fresh food,
organic food, sustainable,
farm to table,
all the rest of it
that comes from
the local markets
that Europe has been
far ahead of America on.
And she comes back to
America after a few years.
And she says, I want to
create a restaurant that
will be a platform
to tell America,
to help America
understand how to eat
better, how to eat
good food-- again,
natural ingredients, organic,
local sourcing, supporting
local farmers,
very high quality.
And she opened up a
restaurant in Oakland,
in Berkeley, by the
name of Chez Panisse.
And some of you will
know who this is.
It's Alice Waters,
legendary chef,
who, along with being this
innovator when it comes
to food, also has, over
the course of her career--
and I'll say so far
because she's still
going strong-- has spawned
literally over 200 people.
Over 200 people that have
worked for her at some
stage in their careers have
gone on to tremendous success
in their own right,
either opening up
their own restaurants,
maybe going
into the bakery business,
the cheese business,
running restaurants, being in
venture capital and finance
around the food industry--
a tremendous track record.
And I said, wow,
here's somebody who's
really kind of
interesting, kind of cool--
and what she has
been able to do.
After a long period of
studying a lot of companies
and doing a lot of work
with a lot of organizations,
I came to realize-- at least in
my mind, is-- I'm going to say,
the single most important
thing for any organization
to survive and thrive
in the long term,
and that is the ability to
generate and regenerate talent
on a continuous basis.
That's what she did.
So I found somebody like that.
And I said, this
is kind of cool.
Let me see if I can
find somebody else.
And I decided, let's look at a
completely different industry.
And I looked at professional
football-- the NFL.
And it turns out that
when you look at the NFL,
there's one head coach that
has had an outsized influence
in the development
of other head coaches
throughout the
history of the NFL.
Does anyone know
who that might be?
Any guesses?
AUDIENCE: Bill Walsh.
SYDNEY FINKELSTEIN:
Bill Walsh, right.
Bill Walsh, San Francisco 49ers.
In fact, one of the nice things
about professional football
and sports is a lot of data.
So I actually could
quantify this.
And so what I did is I looked
at all of the Super Bowl head
coaches of the winning
team and the losing team,
so the two best head coaches
in a particular year.
And I did a genealogical
study of them.
And by that, I mean,
not their parents,
but who they worked for.
And I created these
trees of talent.
And when I did
that, it turned out
that Bill Walsh was far and
away ahead of everybody else.
Number two, by the
way-- we're in Boston,
so I can tell you--
it's Bill Parcells.
And the reason is because
he has one protege that
is in the Super Bowl
almost every year.
And that's Bill Belichick.
And so actually this past year,
back in February in the Super
Bowl, the two head coaches
both came from the Bill Walsh
tree of talent.
This is, by the way,
10 years after he died
and 20 years after
he was a head coach.
I mean, unbelievable legacy.
So I found somebody
in football, pretty
different from
high-end restaurants.
And I thought, OK, this is fun.
Let's keep going.
And then I decided, let's
look at hedge funds.
There's no connection here.
They're just out of the blue.
And hedge funds, turns
out it's Julian Robertson
from Tiger Management.
Some of you who
know that industry
might know-- Tiger
Cubs, Tiger Seeds.
A tremendous number of
people who work for Julian
have become very successful
in the hedge fund business.
And it turns out to be actually
pretty easy to find that.
You start talking to people.
And you ask them.
And everyone keeps
telling you the same name.
And at some point, you
realize you found the guy
or you found the woman.
And so I kept going.
And I ended up looking
at Ralph Lauren
in fashion-- American fashion.
The people that work
for Ralph Lauren-- I
don't know if you
know some of them.
It's a long, long list--
Vera Wang, Tory Burch,
John Varvatos, Joseph Abboud,
the CEO today of Michael Kors--
his name is John Idol--
a long, long list.
Heather mentioned Lorne
Michaels from SNL, George Lucas
for special effects in film,
Roger Corman for B-level films,
actually, for those
of you who follow
that, Larry Ellison for being
Larry Ellison-- about 18
in all, 18 really
different industries.
And so it's kind of interesting.
Every industry I
looked at, I was
able to find the one person
that had this outsized ability--
track record-- of
developing talent.
And that's interesting.
But that's, you know,
just interesting.
What do you do with that?
And so I started studying
them and interviewing them
and interviewing a lot of the
people that work for them,
a lot of the proteges.
Hundreds of interviews over
many years of looking at this.
And what I was interested
in understanding
is, what do they do
that's different?
What do these people do that's
different than other good
bosses or other good leaders?
And that's what I want
to talk about in the time
that we have this afternoon,
some of the highlights of that.
So number one, it
starts with-- and I
call this a superboss playbook--
it starts with talent,
finding great talent.
Now, what does that mean when it
comes to what superbosses did?
Well, they will look for
talent in unusual places.
Bill Walsh is a good
example, actually.
One of the major
reasons why there
are any African American
head coaches in the NFL
is because of Bill Walsh.
He saw an untapped talent
pool-- ex-NFL players,
very smart, very
capable, motivated,
that happened to be
African American.
And he purposely
looked for that talent
and created a variety of
training and development
programs for them.
And they became
assistant coaches for him
and moved all the way up
to becoming a head coach.
In that industry
at that time, that
was an untapped talent pool.
Or Jay Chiat, Chiat-Day-- a big
advertising agency-- Chiat-Day
is the agency that
did the 1984 Apple
ad that's kind of legendary
during the Super Bowl.
And if you've watched
"Mad Men," you
know what's missing at the
top of advertising agencies
in the 1960s and '70s and '80s.
And that's women.
And he saw that, too.
And he said, this is an
untapped talent pool.
That's nuts.
Let's go purposely
seek out women that
have the potential, the talent.
And let's fast-track them
into bigger opportunities.
So one of the nice side effects
of a superboss mindset when
it comes to talent is
you get more diversity.
I don't know they set out to
get diversity in and of itself,
but they got it.
But they got it.
They'll hire people without
a job description, which
traditional HR people,
they kind of freak out
a little bit with that.
There's a famous story
about Ralph Lauren.
He's in a restaurant in New York
with his family having dinner.
And at a table next
to him, there's
a group of three
women, one of whom
is dressed really kind
of cool and special.
And her clothes were
making a statement.
Ralph noticed her.
And over the course
of the dinner--
they're chatting a
little bit on and off.
That happens sometimes.
And Ralph and his family
are done with dinner.
And they get up to leave.
But before he leaves,
he goes over to her
and he takes his
business card out.
And he gives it to
her, and he says--
she didn't recognize who he was,
and he never said his name--
and he says to her, I'd like you
to come in if you have a chance
tomorrow to the office.
I want to offer you a job.
And she looks down and
says, Ralph Lauren?
Ralph Lauren's
offering me a job?
What's going on?
Can you hire thousands
of people like that?
If you have thousands of talent
spotters, you might be able to.
Every single person
in an organization
should become a talent
scout, a talent spotter.
Wherever you go, the
antenna should be up.
Is this someone that
has something special,
some energy, some potential?
It doesn't mean you
hire them on the spot.
But maybe you build the
beginning of a relationship.
You find out what they're doing.
And you look for those
opportunities-- hiring people
without a job description.
What do they look
for specifically?
So there are a lot of
different industries.
So the details differ,
of course, right?
But there were four
characteristics or attributes
that I kept seeing
among the people that
were getting hired that super
bosses liked that they ended up
hiring.
And those four
things were-- number
one is intelligence, extreme
intelligence ideally-- not
just IQ, could be EQ,
emotional intelligence,
relationship skills, depends
on what the business is.
And some of these people
are legendary for this.
Did you ever hear the story
about Larry Ellison about that?
He used to tell his trainers
and his HR people that
were doing interviews,
make sure at some point you
ask the candidate, are you
the smartest person you know?
That's the question.
So how do you answer that?
If you answer yes,
interview continues.
If you answer no, who is?
It's Mary, who I worked
with for a couple years.
And he says, well,
let me go find Mary.
You can go.
The interview's over.
Sounds like a Larry
Ellison thing, doesn't it?
But it gives you an idea of
the extremes to which they
went-- so intelligence.
Creativity-- as you'll see, a
big part of what superbosses do
is they enhance and they
unleash the creativity
of individuals doing
whatever it is they're doing.
Flexibility-- they
like people that
have the aptitude
and interest to do
a lot of different things, that
could be moved from one job
to another to take full
advantage of their skills,
of their mindset, and of
their fresh look at something.
And the fourth thing I kept
seeing was competitiveness.
They love competitive people.
I don't know that all four
of these are originals.
It's not like Google
doesn't want smart people
and doesn't want
competitive people,
doesn't want creative people.
But this is what superbosses
were looking for.
These are the four
things I kept seeing.
Anyway, there's a lot more
I could say about talent.
But I'm just going
to kind of highlight
a few things about
the superboss playbook
to give you a bit of a flavor.
And, you know, depending on
what you ask me afterwards,
I can go into it in
more in more detail.
So you have great talent.
What's the next thing you do?
Well, you've got
to energize them.
You've got to motivate them.
They've got to be
ready for action.
And one thing about living
in a superboss world
is the bar is high.
And it keeps getting higher.
It's not for everyone.
You've got to be willing
to work hard and be
willing to excel at whatever
it is you're going to do.
They're not soft touches.
They're not all the
same personality,
but they're not soft touches.
They push you, and
they push you hard.
I don't think that's all
that shocking, either.
How many people live in a
24/7 world these days anyways?
A lot of people work
really, really hard.
But what superbosses add that
I found many, many managers up
and down organizations don't
do, or don't do very well,
is that they inspire.
They really inspire
the people that
work for them to feel like
there's nothing they can't do.
Again, Ralph Lauren used to
say to the people in his team,
we are the ones that
set the standard.
People-- everyone
else follows us.
We don't follow them.
And you better believe that.
You better be
authentic with that.
You can't fake a
thing like that.
But that was the message
he was communicating.
He truly believed it.
People that worked for Ralph and
many of the other superbosses,
they felt almost like
they were the chosen ones,
that they were special
to have that opportunity.
And the one thing-- in
many of the interviews,
they said something like, the
one thing I never wanted to do
is let my boss down.
I never did wanted to let Tommy
Frist-- CEO of HCA-- I never
wanted to let him down.
So they inspire people.
They energize people.
And that is a really
important part
of being an effective leader,
no matter what job you've got.
Because you've
got to give people
a reason why they need
to go through brick walls
and do unbelievable things.
And some people are
internally motivated.
But at some point,
people burn out also.
And that inspiration
part, if it's genuine,
if it's authentic,
it's a gigantic factor
that keeps people in
the game and makes
them feel like they're really
accomplishing something,
something special.
Related to that is the V
word, the "vision" word.
It's absolutely true
that superbosses have
these broad, powerful visions.
Alice Waters, from Chez
Panisse restaurant,
her vision was to create a
world-- create a restaurant
as this platform, as I said,
to change the way America eats.
That's a gigantic, crazy vision.
George Lucas had a
vision to create what
eventually became "Star Wars."
But there was no technology
available to do it.
He had to invent-- which
is really kind of amazing--
he had to invent countless
new digital technologies
to accomplish that.
But that was the vision
he was driving towards.
Ralph Lauren is the same
way, this idea of clothes
being part of your
lifestyle and integrating it
in a way that's consistent
with his image of life
is a movie, really.
They have these visions.
And you know, they will not
compromise on those visions.
If you don't like
that vision, if you
can't live with that vision,
you will not succeed.
You may be hired.
It would be a mistake.
And you will not last.
You have to buy into the vision.
I call this-- one
of the chapters,
the title of the chapter
is "Uncompromisingly Open."
So you heard the
uncompromising part, but what
about the open part?
And this is one of these
counterintuitive things
that superbosses do.
At the same time as having
this expansive vision--
at the same time, they
unleash the creativity
of the people in
their organizations,
of their team members,
of their peers.
And the reason they do that is
because they feel so strongly
about fulfilling whatever
their goal is, their vision is,
that they want every
idea you've got.
They want all the best ideas.
They don't think they've
got all the answers.
They are constantly looking
for better solutions.
So often I heard
from my interviews
this idea of how a superboss
would be so excited
and found it so
rewarding to learn
something new from someone
who worked for her or for him.
Many, many bosses have a
very different philosophy
about that.
But they loved the idea
of learning something.
And they love a good fight.
They love a good disagreement.
I mean, of course, Larry
Ellison is famous for that.
But every one of the
superbosses were.
And it doesn't mean you
always win the battle
or win the argument
with your boss.
But they loved-- they
wanted someone that could--
that was willing to go for
it, had something to say.
You said it.
And if you thought
it's the right idea,
you engage in the discussion.
And you're not afraid to tell
your boss or your colleagues,
"you know, I think you're
wrong about this; here's why"
in an analytical, careful way.
They love that.
They value that.
And so you have an
interesting situation
where you have this
uncompromising vision,
but yet all these ideas,
whatever you've got,
is important.
Creativity becomes part
of your everyday job,
no matter what it is you do.
If you're trying to
create something new,
you might have some skunk
works or some task force.
That might happen.
But more likely than
not, everyone every day
is supposed to keep thinking
of new ways of doing things.
And if you work for someone like
that, or with people like that,
it's pretty exciting, isn't it?
I mean, it's pretty powerful
because it means you count.
It means every individual
has the potential
to make a difference.
You may know about
employee engagement scores,
which Gallup keeps reporting.
And they vary a lot, of course.
But the biggest survey from
Gallup from about a year
ago showed something like
25% of all employees rated
said that they were
highly engaged at work.
I mean, 25%.
That's unbelievable.
That means 75% said either
they were not engaged
or a little bit engaged or just
a touch engaged, or whatever.
Not highly engaged-- I
mean, that's unbelievable.
That's not just a managerial
failure or a leadership
failure.
That's actually a moral failure,
if you really think about it.
That so many people
go to work and don't
feel fulfilled in
any particular way
from that work, that's wrong.
And leaders need
to do everything
they can to make sure that
doesn't happen in their world.
And the benefits are
endless because you end up
with better talent.
You end up with more
motivated, energized talent.
As a result, you do better.
They do better.
The organization will do better.
And yet you'll be helping
them accomplish more.
So if you put together what I've
said so far, what did I say?
They find unusual talent.
They look for them-- they look
for diamonds in the rough.
And they push them hard.
And they create a
high-performance culture.
And they inspire them to really
feel like they can do anything.
And they have a vision
that is motivating,
and it's exciting that
you want to be part of.
And you unleash the creativity
of people around you.
What kind of organization
do you create
when you do a thing like that?
I mean, it's a pretty amazing
thing that you can do.
And, in fact, you create an
organization that, I think,
will be much more adaptable
and adjustable and agile,
if you want to use
that word, than a lot
of other organizations
and a lot of other teams.
Some of you may know--
either from reading
something or business school or
who knows where-- but there's
a dominant model of change or
change management in business.
Almost everyone around the
world that's a senior executive
seems to know this.
And it came from some
work by John Kotter at HBS
over a number of decades.
And the model is that if
you want people to change,
you need to create
a sense of urgency.
It's a common term, right?
You've got to give people
a real sense of urgency,
or the other term people
use is a "burning platform,"
create a burning platform
to get people to change.
I mean, think about that.
Isn't that crazy?
You need to have your house
virtually on fire before you
do anything about it?
You need to be almost
in the hospital
before you start eating
better or exercising?
Why do we need to create a
view of the world of change
that we have to be in
a disastrous situation
before we actually do
something about that?
A lot of big companies have
fallen by the wayside exactly
because of that mentality.
Jim Collins, famous from
"Good to Great," of course,
wrote a book called "Built to
Last" a few years before that.
And I think "Built to Last"
is the wrong metaphor.
I think actually
what we want in teams
and in organizations is
to be built to change.
I think built to change is much
more powerful because that's
going to allow you--
or at least increase
the odds of you being adaptable,
adjustable, flexible, agile,
dealing with the
famous disruptions that
are going on
everywhere, and being
ahead of the curve in that.
And the irony is, I think, when
you create an organization that
is built to change, you
actually last a lot longer.
So the superboss mindset,
the superboss playbook,
is not just about leadership.
It's not just about how
to work more effectively.
It's not just about helping
other people get better,
although it's about
all of those things.
It's also building
an organization
that's much more adaptable,
adjustable, and agile.
Let me say one last part-- and
I'm skipping over a few things
so we can get to
that afterwards.
But one last part of
the superboss playbook
that I think is
important-- and then we'll
open up for some questions,
see you want to talk about.
I didn't really say anything
about how superbosses develop
talent on a day-to-day basis.
And so let me say a
little bit about that.
And it turns out that over
a matter of centuries,
there has been one
dominant method
of people learning their
craft or their skill
or their capability.
And it's been going on,
really, for centuries.
And, of course, that's called
an apprenticeship, right?
That's how it works.
Leonardo da Vinci
was in the workshop
of Verrocchio in Florence.
That's how he learned at
the beginning of his career,
when he was 13 years old,
when he went in the work.
Everyone learned that way.
But where are these
apprenticeships today?
Some companies say or
tell me, yeah, we do that.
But I haven't seen
very much of it.
It's unusual.
And maybe you'll see it
for some technical skills,
but for management and for
leadership, much less likely.
And so what
superbosses have done
is they've resurrected, in
their own way, an apprenticeship
model to developing talent.
So let me tell you in
brief what that means.
Number one-- big
opportunities for people.
If you see someone
that has potential,
you look for big opportunities.
You delegate big to them.
I gave a talk to a different
group not that long ago,
and there's a CHRO,
Chief HR Officer,
of a Fortune 100
company that was there.
In the Q&A, he raised his hand.
And he said, I want to tell
you what happened to me.
When I was 28 years old, my
boss gave me an assignment
to go to Japan and become
the HR director in Japan
at the age of 28.
And he wasn't a Japanese native.
He wasn't a Japanese speaker.
And he told his boss,
no, you're crazy.
There's no way I can do that.
And his boss, of course,
told him-- or his superboss
told him, I wouldn't
ask you to do it,
I would give you this
opportunity if I wasn't very,
very sure you could do it.
And I'll support you
in the beginning,
but then you're going
to figure it out.
And so he ended up doing that.
He was there, I think,
for four or five years.
And as he was
describing it, he talked
about how it changed his
life because he did something
that was really, really hard.
He worked like crazy to do it.
I mean, the cultural difference,
the language difference--
you can imagine.
And at that age, as
well, in a culture
that's quite-- where
hierarchy and age means a lot.
But he did it.
And he succeeded.
And after that, he felt like
there's nothing he couldn't do,
that there's nothing
he couldn't accomplish.
And I'm sure that some of
you, maybe many of you,
have had either a boss or
a colleague or maybe even
a teacher that has given
you that gift, given you
this tremendous opportunity
that when you accomplish that,
you fulfill that, it's just--
it accelerates your career.
It builds tremendous confidence.
And that's also a
gift that you can
do when you have people that
work for you or your colleagues
as well, to give them those
types of opportunities.
That's a big part of
the apprentice approach.
I'll say two other things
about the apprentice approach
and then finally, Q&A.
Along with big delegation
and opportunities, it
turns out that superbosses
don't just delegate and forget.
They will roll up their
sleeves and work very closely
with people on their
team periodically.
They will get close to that
line that everybody tells
you don't want to be
close to, the line
that starts with "micro"
and ends with "management."
That's a bad thing,
everybody says that.
And I don't call
them micromanagers
in any traditional sense.
To me, a micromanager
is someone that
does their team members' work.
They don't do that.
But they don't exactly
ignore what's going on.
They will parachute
in sometimes.
They'll show up at meetings.
They'll spend half a day
going through a project.
And what are they doing?
They're not doing your work,
but they're teaching you.
They're pushing you.
They're changing the
rules of the game
as you're going along to
try to understand it better.
It's like getting a
one-on-one tutorial
with a true master,
somebody who's
been doing something
for 10 or 20 years,
or even two or three
years, depending
on the industry--
very, very powerful.
Very, very powerful.
And a lot of people look
at this and say, well,
how can that happen?
Many people talk about-- you
ask them about their boss,
they say, well, my boss
is a big delegator.
And other people say, I'm stuck
with-- she's a micromanager.
It turns out as soon as
you open your head and say,
these are not the same
continuum, where you're either
a delegate or a micromanager,
but there's two lines going on
at the same time.
And you can be a big delegator
and a small delegator.
Or you could be a big
micromanager and a very little
micromanager.
As soon as you realize
that, which is true,
you could imagine how these
two things could be combined.
So I actually have a
lot more I could say.
But I want to leave
time to talk about what
you want to talk about.
So should we open
it up for some Q&A?
And I'll weave in a
few other stories.
But I'm really
interested in what you're
wondering about from this.
AUDIENCE: I have two questions.
The first is, you're talking
a lot about the superbosses
from the point at which
they already are bosses.
And maybe I missed
this at the beginning,
but I'm curious if
there are any patterns
about their own development,
too, before they were bosses?
So that's one thing.
And then the second
thing was, you mentioned
George Lucas and his vision.
And I have always
found it interesting
how he sold the
franchise to Disney.
And part of it is knowing
when to let go of your vision
and move on.
And I wonder just
your thoughts on that.
It seemed kind of early in
terms of giving it away,
but maybe that's part of the key
of being able to develop a halo
effect of other people
taking on your vision
and adapting it for their own.
So those are my two questions.
SYDNEY FINKELSTEIN:
Right, right.
So first on the
George Lucas thing,
I think that's probably pretty
unusual from the superbosses
that I talked to
or that I studied,
that they would give it up.
But he was a certain age.
And you got one of these offers
you can't refuse type of thing,
right?
And who would be the best
owner of these assets,
if it's not George
Lucas himself?
Most people would
probably say, a company
that knows how to
do stuff like that.
But that wasn't
a common pattern.
Most people went-- I mean,
Ralph Lauren, what is he, 75
or something like that?
He just now recently appointed
a new CEO, and he's the chair.
So he's not ready to step aside.
Julian Robertson's 80 years old.
He's still somewhat-- not nearly
as much-- somewhat involved.
So the first
question, how do you
get to-- what do
they do along the way
to become that superboss?
So one thing is
true-- superbosses
do create more superbosses.
So I saw that by
many of the proteges
that I talked to-- I call
them proteges, but former team
members.
In many instances-- and
not all, because there's
some attrition-- but
in many instances,
they learned-- I asked in my
interviews, what did you learn?
And that could be an hour-long
discussion around that.
And it was very specific.
And it almost always included,
along with some very specific
things to that
industry, a lot of ideas
about developing talent,
thinking about people
a little bit differently.
And I think the other
thing that's-- I can't say
it's a conclusion; it's more
like an observation-- is,
a number of superbosses really
felt like they had something
to prove, almost like they
had a chip on their shoulder,
which doesn't make you--
if you measure that,
does that predict
being a superboss?
No.
But going backwards, I say,
actually, a surprising number
did-- Larry Ellison
and Norman Brinker
from casual restaurant
industry, a whole bunch of them.
Bill Walsh was passed over as
the head coach for-- I think
it was Cincinnati Bengals
or Cleveland Browns,
one or the other-- when he was
ready, thought he was ready.
And he vowed right then
that when he has a chance
to be a head coach, he's
never going to do that
to someone who's ready.
And actually what he
did, which is really
unusual-- I didn't talk
about this part yet--
but Bill Walsh would actually,
when there was a head coach
opening, he would actually pick
up the phone and call an owner
and tell the owner,
you should hire
one of my assistant coaches
if he thought they were ready.
And that's really extreme
because you are now
giving one of your best
talents to a direct competitor.
But that's kind of what he did.
He felt so strongly about that.
So there's a couple
thoughts about that.
AUDIENCE: The way that you're
describing superbosses sounds
like a very personal experience,
like person-to-person
experience while will
grow like a tree,
doesn't really
scale that quickly.
Have you seen any examples
where the superboss lessons
have been institutionalized or
taught in a more rapid pace?
SYDNEY FINKELSTEIN:
Right, that's
a great, great
question about scaling.
And early on, as
part of the research,
I studied
superboss-like companies
to see what they had done.
In the end, I ended up
interested in the origins
of how does it start?
Because it starts-- it always
starts with people, number one.
And number two, any individual
can be a more effective leader
by adopting the superboss ideas.
So that's why I did it that way.
But in fact, there are
a number of examples.
I mean, some are famous.
GE has been known for that,
for having that reputation.
But McKinsey is like that.
I think at one point,
Goldman Sachs was.
One of my best examples
that I looked at
is actually Second City, the
comedy group from Chicago,
or actually around the
world now, Second City.
I started to look at
Second City because I
was interested-- was there
another superboss in the comedy
world besides Lorne
Michaels from SNL?
And I couldn't find
anyone within Second City.
And I thought that was cool and
interesting because they have
produced hundreds of talent.
So how'd that happen?
And then I ended up spending
a long time with them
and did a whole big analysis.
And it turns out it had been
inculcated into their culture.
Many of the things
I'm talking about,
it wasn't one person doing it.
It was a whole bunch
of people doing it.
Now how do you actually
make that happen now,
as opposed to studying a company
or in organizations like that?
That's where I'm spending
a ton of my time on.
I think you actually
can do that.
First of all, you need to
know whether you have-- not
whether, because every
company has superbosses.
Every company has superbosses.
I know this because-- you
probably think about it,
and you know superbosses.
But I've signed-- I've done
a lot of book signings.
And people ask me to
sign the book over
to their boss, who
is a superboss.
And they tell me the
story about that person.
And it's somebody I never
heard of in a company
that I barely knew existed.
There are plenty.
But do we know who they
are in our organization?
That seems like a baby step.
And I'm doing that
in my own work
right now, with an assessment.
Why aren't we trying to
measure whether we have
any superbosses, and then
figure out what are they
doing that has been tailored
to this particular culture,
and then figure out a way
to teach that or share that?
There's also, like any
type of attempt to scale,
there's an entire curriculum
that we're actually developing.
You could imagine, it's not
like classroom curriculum.
It will be a platform
and other things that
will help people become
more effective as leaders,
adopting a bunch of
the superboss ideas.
So if you're starting
with none of that,
it's going to take some time.
Is it scalable?
I think it is because I
see these companies exist.
It's not going to
happen overnight.
AUDIENCE: You have
talked about superbosses,
people who manage teams and
inspire people to do something.
Have you studied
superteachers, people
who teach people and inspire
them to learn more to educate
themselves, and so on?
SYDNEY FINKELSTEIN:
Superteachers?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
SYDNEY FINKELSTEIN: So
they're very similar,
as far as I could tell.
In academia, the idea of
having a famous academic
that has a lot of PhD students
that go on to great success,
that's there in every field.
I think there's even a
website for mathematicians
that come from-- some of
you will know who it is;
I don't remember the name--
some very famous mathematician,
many, many-- an incredible
number of people.
In my own field of
studying organizations,
there are two really famous--
there are a lot of famous,
but there are two
really famous people
that go back in time
that kind of set--
that wrote a bunch of
books and other things
that became highly,
highly influential.
And one of them is named Jim
March, who is still around,
and the other one is Herb Simon.
Now, Herb Simon might be a
name some of you may recognize.
He won a Nobel
Prize in economics,
the first non-traditional
economist to win that.
Fascinating-- Jim
March today, you
could look at hundreds
of his family tree
that are among the absolute
leaders around the world
in organizational studies in
business schools and companies
and consulting
firms and the like.
And you look at Herb
Simon, and there's hardly
anyone, which is really
kind of fascinating.
It's just not what
he wanted to do.
So I didn't study it formally.
I do have in the book
a story about what
I learned from my own superboss,
my own PhD mentor and advisor,
that was remarkably similar
to what these others did.
But I'm quite certain that if I
were to do that type of study,
it would be actually
kind of easy.
I think there would
be people like that
in virtually every field.
And I suspect in
some ways, they'll
be even more like the classic
superboss in the sense
that when you are in
academia, when you're
working under a professor,
you will almost always
have to leave.
You get a degree.
You've got to get a
job somewhere else.
And that's the hallmark
of what superbosses do.
You look at an
industry, and you see
a lot of the very
successful people,
and a disproportionate
number of them
all came from the same person.
But in a corporate
setting, we say,
well, we don't want to
lose all our best talent.
We want to keep
some of that talent.
And in an academic setting,
that's just the way it works.
You might bring him
back at some point,
but almost everyone ends up
going off somewhere else.
So a couple of
thoughts about that.
AUDIENCE: You talk a little
bit about superbosses
being able to identify
other superbosses.
But what about
someone who's looking
to identify a
superboss who doesn't
know they're a superboss?
How do you go the other
way and find the mentors
you want to work with?
SYDNEY FINKELSTEIN:
Right, right.
So I think this is a great--
I mean, it's a great question,
a great thing to think about.
When I talk about this
with my MBA students,
it's the number one question.
I talk about it
with undergraduates,
and it's the number one
question, of course.
But I think it's
relevant for anyone
almost at any stage of career.
So I'm a big fan
of-- when you're
in an interview with
your prospective boss,
I think you want
to really plan out
how you will interview
the interviewer.
It's not a one-way street.
It's a two-way street.
And what do you want to know?
Well, I would want
to know-- and I'm not
going to give you the
right wording exactly--
but what I want to
know is, well, tell me
about some of the people
that used to work for you.
Where are they today?
What do you want to hear?
Some superstars--
people you've heard of,
or at least people
you can check on later
that have done really well.
Do you stay in touch with people
that used to work for you?
How often are there job
openings in your team?
You can kind of figure
that out even before that.
This is actually one of the
metrics I've been playing with.
And I'd be curious
about reaction
to that, which is, in a company
you have these internal job
boards or whatever
you call them.
You've got them, too.
And if there's a manager, where
whenever there's a job opening,
it gets closed up really
fast versus a manager
where it seems to
always be-- they always
need to be hiring somebody.
And they're growing
at the same pace.
You've got a control
for that, right?
I won't say it's definitive,
but it's indicative
that the manager
where everyone keeps
wanting to get into that place
and the jobs close down fast,
there's something
going on there.
People know.
And internally, you tend--
you get to know a lot.
So another way to do it is
keep your eyes open and alert.
Be mindful, if you will, about
the people that you work with
and the people that you
interact with in and outside
of Google, for that
matter, for people
that seem to have some of
what I'm talking about.
And one other thing I'd like
to ask-- well, I don't ask,
but I recommend asking; I
don't need a job anymore--
I like to ask the
interviewer-- I'd
like you to ask the interviewer,
how do you spend your day?
What does a typical
day look like?
So it's a trick question,
because if they say, well, I'm
in meetings from
morning to night,
you don't have a superboss.
Superbosses will
never let themselves
get so choreographed,
so locked up
so they have no time to just
kind of plop down next to you
and spend 30 minutes
drilling into you
to push you a
little harder, make
sure you're doing what
you should be doing,
and maybe get your feedback.
Of course you have meetings.
If I can get rid
of meetings, I'm
going to be on Mount
Rushmore or something.
But do we have to have
meetings all day long?
And some people,
they let that happen.
I consider that the
fault of the individual,
not the fault of anyone else.
You can control that.
Some meetings
you've got to go to.
But you don't have
to go to everything.
Anyways, so that's another-- I'm
sure there are bunch of others.
Actually, as I think
about it, I think
in the last chapter,
chapter 9, I
think I have a bunch of other--
some of these, and probably
a few other questions
that you could
ask or at least
look for when you're
trying to find a superboss.
AUDIENCE: For a fair
amount of people,
they don't have much
interest in actually
being a manager or a boss.
But are there any skills that
you find that superbosses have
or that people who are not
looking to manage can leverage?
SYDNEY FINKELSTEIN: Yeah,
great, great question.
So, in fact, I think
many of the things
that superbosses do that
help other people get better
are good things.
Because it's a good thing to
help other people get better.
They're colleagues of yours.
Nobody really works alone.
So they are peers, they could
be task forces, whatever.
And so, for example,
feedback is a gigantic thing.
Superbosses-- all good managers,
really-- love feedback,
constant feedback.
You know this-- I'm not
sure how Google does this,
but there's been
such a trend now
finally towards blowing up the
annual performance review that
has gotten so many-- it destroys
more than it creates value.
And what you should
be doing is constant
feedback-- you giving
it, you taking it.
So that's an easy one to do
for anyone, whether you've
got a boss or not, right?
The creativity
side is challenging
people that are working
with you because you
want to learn from them.
I think you can do that.
I think the idea of even being
a talent scout or a talent
spotter might be relevant.
It's not that you're
hiring them for your team,
but you care about your company
or your unit or your team,
and you want to look for great--
you want to surround yourself
with other great people.
Probably if we went
through every one
of the elements
of the playbook--
I don't know about
all of the elements,
but I bet a bunch
of them will be,
I think, easily transferable.
AUDIENCE: I have a question,
just building on that.
So one of the things that I
had written down very similarly
to what you had said is
this idea of superteams,
or the point of how peers
cultivate talent, which
you addressed.
I'm wondering if you found any
also like, superpartnerships,
so people who have
partnered together that
have developed something
special between each other
and really develop talent?
I think about Larry
and Sergei, right?
We're all probably thinking
about a lot of Google examples.
SYDNEY FINKELSTEIN: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Did you find any of
these partnerships or teams?
I think Second City might
be an example of it.
SYDNEY FINKELSTEIN: Well,
a really good example
is Lennon-McCartney.
I'm reading yet another
book on the Beatles,
so it's fresh in my mind.
When John Lennon
wrote a great song,
Paul McCartney said, I'm
going write a better song.
When McCartney
wrote a great song,
Lennon said, well, I was
about to say what he said.
He's going to write-- he's
going to create a better song.
But at the same time, virtually
every song they wrote,
they collaborated.
Paul would show up with John.
He'd have the
beginning and the end.
He'd have the tune.
But it's missing the middle
eight, as they call it,
or vice versa.
So this is one of the kind
of really interesting things
that when it comes to teams
or maybe partnerships,
combining collaboration and
competition-- another one
of these things that
most people think
are different or opposite,
which they could be.
But in fact, combining
collaboration and competition
at the same time could
actually bring out the best.
My favorite example of
that actually is SNL.
I interviewed John Lennon--
not yet-- Lorne Michaels
a couple of times.
And he told me this-- that he
came up with this strategy,
if you will.
And he realized this is great.
And he kept doing it.
And what is it?
To get on SNL, like, for
a performer to get airtime
on SNL, how do you do it?
It's not a stand-up
comedy show, right?
So you've got to collaborate.
You've got to form a skit.
You need a writer or two.
You need another
performer or two.
And that's the definition
of collaboration.
But what Lorne Michaels does
is, as you get closer to Friday
night, he creates
typically as much as two
and a half hours of
content or material.
But the show's only
an hour and a half.
And so in the last
36 to 48 hours,
you need some
pretty sharp elbows
to get your airtime on
there because you're
going from two and a half
hours to one and a half hours.
And he purposely was doing this.
And he said, this is,
like, unbelievable,
because they've got
to work together.
But at the same
time, I want to see
who's got that fire, who
can improve their game so
much that the audience-- it's
not just him because they do
these multiple rehearsals
in front of audiences--
the audience is going
to love it so much.
So that's competition.
It's a scarce resource.
Everybody wants that.
So yeah, that combination
is pretty interesting.
AUDIENCE: I have an
obvious question.
I'm sure you're asked
this all the time.
Maybe you address
it in the book.
I haven't read the book.
I glanced at the introduction.
It looks as though,
of the superbosses
you interviewed,
unless I missed some,
only one was a
woman, Alice Waters.
I think you mentioned
you considered Hillary
Clinton and Oprah Winfrey.
But I was just
noticing yesterday
that the law firm
Cravath, Swain & Moore
just appointed its
first-ever female leader.
And apparently of the top 200
law firms in the United States,
only three are led by women.
It seems to me that, in
all of the characteristics
you're talking about
about superbosses,
nothing strikes me as
inherently biased against women
particularly.
Of everything
you've talked about,
I don't see a reason
why there shouldn't
be a lot more women
who have already
attained superboss status.
So what are your thoughts
on this whole issue?
Why don't we have more?
Are we going to have
more in the future?
What are the barriers?
SYDNEY FINKELSTEIN:
Yeah, I came up
against that as part of
the research process.
And I started searching.
And I wasn't
particularly successful.
I mentioned Sheryl
Sandberg in brief.
You mention Hillary Clinton.
Only for one part of
the superboss playbook--
I didn't really talk much
about it-- is the network.
And some people consider
that a disaster.
And some people
consider it fantastic.
But she has an
unbelievable network.
Oprah Winfrey, in terms
of developing talent,
is a good example.
Ann Richards, the former
governor of Texas.
But not that many.
And I thought about it a lot.
And in part for me
to find them, there
needs to be a track record
of developing talent
that have gotten
to senior positions
because that was my
research strategy.
Well, that takes some time.
And that means
you would have had
to be in a very senior
position 10, 20, 30 years ago.
And of course, the
sample size is tiny.
So I think that's the biggest
reason why that happened.
What do I predict?
I think it will
become-- if I were
to come back in around 10 years,
I think it'll be more balanced.
Not completely
balanced, because you
can look at who are the CEOs
today and they're still many
more men than women.
You look at the Fortune 500,
you look at board members,
you look at senior executives--
still very, very unbalanced.
But it will be better.
It will be better.
So I didn't think there
was anything innately
odd about what I was finding.
I think it's
circumstance during due
to the stage of
where we are in terms
of the leadership in the
economy, to a large extent,
and hopefully will
become a little bit less
imbalanced over time.
Can I ask everyone a question?
Yeah?
My question is this-- it
should be right up your alley.
How do you measure whether
a company has superbosses?
So I have an assessment.
It is a survey.
It's been validated over
several hundred participants.
And we've done all kinds
of statistical validation
reliability.
It's pretty good.
But that's just one--
and it's a survey.
So it depends on a 360.
It depends on a lot of things.
And that's always a
small sample size.
But I want to figure
out, how do you know?
I mean, I just had this
conversation with a senior HR
person at a big company.
And he said, well,
how do you really know
whether you have superbosses?
And my primary answer
is, well, the assessment.
I can help you with that.
But I know that's not enough.
And then I said, well,
you know, maybe-- I
forgot who asked the
question-- but when there's
a team that has a revolving
door versus a team where
as soon as there's an opening,
it gets closed quickly.
You can track that type of data.
That's something.
You look at financial
performance, presumably.
Maybe you can count
how many people
have gone on to bigger jobs
as a percentage over time
or some such thing.
But I haven't gotten
further than that.
So just off the top of your
head, were there any thoughts?
AUDIENCE: I assume that if
the progression of people
into superbosses as they're
being mentored and apprenticed
follows a given pattern that the
org chart of the organization
would reflect that over time.
SYDNEY FINKELSTEIN:
The org chart
would reflect what exactly?
AUDIENCE: So if the
people in control
are raising up-- giving
big opportunities to people
underneath them and
raising up more people that
can take on larger
portions of the business,
I'd think that the org chart
might be flatter at the higher
levels or maybe take
on some other form that
could be identified
versus someone who
may be very good
at the business,
but is not delegating, not
bringing up people under them.
SYDNEY FINKELSTEIN:
That's possible.
It's true that one of the other
characteristics of superbosses
is they hate-- maybe
everybody hates bureaucracy
and hierarchy-- but they just
whack away at it constantly
because they want to be
with people doing real work.
They don't want to
have multiple layers.
I know that's a
Google thing as well.
AUDIENCE: So many
companies have, like,
the 360 review or manager
surveys during the year.
And so I think it's about
aligning those metrics.
So you could do case
studies on certain companies
where the things that they're
asking the understudies--
and, I guess, the bosses--
about are aligned with what
you've identified in your book.
And then, if they're graded this
way, then you can quantify it.
SYDNEY FINKELSTEIN: So it's
part of the internal measurement
or metrics of whether
you're a good manager.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SYDNEY FINKELSTEIN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And you can
work with those companies,
I guess, like Oracle or
whoever, to try that.
SYDNEY FINKELSTEIN:
Mm-hmm, good.
AUDIENCE: To your
question, did you
come across any situations in
which you interviewed people
who you considered to be
superbosses who describe
past scenarios in which the
kind of institutional structure
of where they were was limiting
of their superboss potentials,
for instance, and then they
left to go somewhere else?
Because I came from the world
of government and politics,
where bureaucracy is very rigid.
And it makes it very
difficult for people
who are even charismatic
leaders to have that involvement
with their staff.
And then you see a lot of
trends of people moving
to, for instance, the tech
industry, where things
are a lot more open and flat.
Do you encounter that in
your interviews at all?
SYDNEY FINKELSTEIN:
More for the proteges
than the actual
superbosses, who are
some of these legendary people.
Proteges have done a
bunch of different things.
Yeah, there was some
movement towards that.
And maybe that's a reflection
of-- certain cultures,
if you will-- or structures,
in your example--
are more amenable to superboss
approaches and techniques.
And others are less so,
which I think is right.
I think that's right.
AUDIENCE: In the
tech industry, I
would say that stints
can be shorter.
And we see a lot
of that is in-- so
who follows the person when
the person leaves and goes
on to a new venture?
So like, kind of measuring
and looking at follow-up--
SYDNEY FINKELSTEIN: Are you
bringing your team with you?
That type of thing.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so we see
a lot of like, for example,
we've seen a lot of it with
Sheryl going to Facebook
and then pulling-- eventually,
once the non-compete runs out--
pulling a number of people
with her or others, right?
We see a lot of that.
And they kind of end up
assembling a similar team
underneath them.
SYDNEY FINKELSTEIN:
Right, right.
We'll end on my favorite--
one of my favorite stories.
I can't say my favorite
because they're all my babies.
They're all favorites.
So one of the superbosses--
I don't profile him
in very much detail even though
I did a big study of him--
is Robert Mondavi
from, of course,
the wine business in Napa.
He created, essentially,
the US wine business.
Almost-- not almost
everyone, but a lot
of people that became
successful in the wine business
at some point worked for him
and were influenced by him.
And so a couple-- two or
three years ago, or maybe
four or five years ago--
one of my consulting clients
is a company called
Constellation Brands.
It's the world's biggest
spirits and wine company.
They're gigantic.
And they bought the Mondavi
company probably 10 years
earlier, when he was retired.
And so we did an
all-day retreat in Napa.
And the top 40 executives
from around the world
from this company came in.
And we were spending the day
doing what you do in retreats.
And the dinner was going to
be at the Mondavi Ranch, which
they owned, of course, right?
And they invited Mr.
Mondavi and his wife
to dinner, which was nice.
He was long retired.
And so he came.
And he was in a wheelchair.
He was 94, I believe.
And he didn't say anything.
It wasn't clear what
he understood or not.
I mean, he was
dressed in a suit.
His wife had to help him eat.
He obviously was
struggling a little bit
at that stage of life.
And I happened to be seated
at the same table as him.
And as dinner is
about to begin, I
noticed a couple of the senior
executives from Constellation
start walking towards our
table from another table.
And they're going
towards Mr. Mondavi.
And the next thing I
know I turn around,
and I realize there's like,
a line of 20 people waiting
their turn to talk
to Mr. Mondavi.
And you have to picture this.
So he's in a
wheelchair, so they have
to kind of kneel down a little
bit to make eye contact.
And you know what they say?
Almost without exception,
they say, thank you.
Thank you for what you've done.
Thank you for what
you've created.
Thank you for creating
this incredible opportunity
that I've been able
to be part of this
and create a livelihood
for my family and all that
you-- and he--
one after another,
the same type of thing.
It was really-- you see
that, you don't forget that.
And he never said a word.
He didn't say anything.
And I don't know whether he
really understood or not.
But his eyes were sparkling.
So I like to think
he understood.
And that's legacy, isn't it?
I mean, that's an
unbelievable thing.
When all is said
and done, are we--
each of us-- going
to have people
that have been
influenced, where we
have been able to change
their lives for the better
in some way, that's a really
powerful thing that goes way
beyond wealth and
many other things.
And superbosses have done it.
Superbosses have done it.
And I think any one of
us have that opportunity
to be able to do that.
So thank you very much.
Good luck to everyone.
I hope to see many more
superbosses here again.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.